it's that time of the month again the
six free playstation games for october
have been announced
like always you'll receive two
PlayStation 4 games 2 PlayStation 3 and
2 for the Vita as well this month we
have action racing another visual novel
a god game and the greatest survival
horror game in history let's start off
with the big guns on ps4 and to
celebrate the 20th anniversary of the
Reds and Evil franchise we are given the
HD remake of the original Resident Evil
game
you steer Jill Valentine or Chris
Redfield through a horror mansion in a
genre-defining outing the terrible
dialogue from the early 90s has been
updated and feels as cinematic as a film
not the Resident Evil films of course
they weren't the best were they this is
easily the game of the month and is a
must for all PlayStation aficionados
we'll be doing a remake versus original
video later this month
so please stay tuned next up is
transformers devastation this is one for
the younglings and the veterans alike as
the modern Transformers films have
reunited with their 80s counterparts in
this action title playing more like a
hack and slash game this one has you
fighting Megatron through Optimus Prime
the 80s Optimus I must add this is great
fun and worth a few hours of your time
and anywhere anything using cel-shading
has to be grit right before we switch
over to the ps3 please help us out by
clicking that subscribe button it lets
us know you like these videos now over
to the ps3 and mud riders as the title
suggests it's a racing game which
doesn't take yourself very seriously
featuring ATVs instead of the typical
motorcycles and straight-up racing cars
this is a game for Speed Freaks playing
in a similar vein to MotorStorm with a
few parallels to burnout paradise 2 this
is one for all you our kid racers out
there from dust is a difficult game to
explain but basically you play God I'll
let you decide which one in this title
you'll be changing the landscape of your
world if you need one of your minions to
go to the sea then cut the Mourad
through the mountain this is similar to
settlers if your result of me but
instead of directly influencing each
settler you change the world around them
I
love this one and gave it 8.5 out of 10
whereas Steam users disagreed slightly
and on the give it 6 out of 10
over to the Vita for two very different
games indeed actual sunlight is a
narrative escapade with a quirky 8-bit
graphic style don't be fooled by the
cartoony style though as it is centered
around sadness depression and suicide
the dark themes are key to this
brilliantly constructed title but this
is not a feel-good game so unless you
are open-minded and if you carry the
burden of another person's bleak outlook
on life it's probably best to give it a
mix finally a code realize guardians of
rebirth yes that's really what it's
called is our last offering on beta and
carries a whopping 86% on Metacritic
this game follows the trends of visual
novels which have really come to
prominence in the last 12 months this
journey is centered around a character
named kardia who's locked away in a
tower by her father
featuring superb writing and character
development this one should be
downloaded if you own a Vita so they
were our six free games for the month of
October 2016 I personally can't wait to
get my hands on Resident Evil and make
congeal sandwich
what will you'll be downloading in
October please let us know below please
do as a favor and subscribe to our
Channel we really want it to grow and we
need your help I've been Adam for
PlayStation granade see you next time